vor etwas mehr als zehn Jahren sahen wir
alle mit Erstaunen diese übertriebene
schauspielerten Aufnahmen
am 17 dezember 2011 starb der
nordkoreanische Diktator Kim Jong el an
einem Herzinfarkt er hatte Nordkorea 17
Jahre lang von 1994 bis 2011 mit
eiserner Faust regiert und während seine
Herrschaft erlebte das Land die
schlimmste Hungersnot seiner Geschichte
diese wurde unter dem euphemistischen
Begriff mühsamer Marsch bekannt in
dessen Verlauf nach unterschiedlichen
Schätzungen zwischen einer halben und
dreieinhalb Millionen Menschen
verhungert
tatsache ist das nach dem Tod King Jong
ist sein Sohn Kim Jong und die Macht
übernommen hat und dieser sah damals
überhaupt nicht wie nach einer
Hungersnot aus heute ist er ein
international anerkanntes
Staatsoberhaupt aber damals war sein
Profil wieder innehalten noch außerhalb
Nordkorea sonderlich bekannt der
Machtübergang dauerte von Dezember 2011
bis April 2012 und endete damit dass der
29-Jährige kim Jong ohne die volle
Kontrolle über die Arbeiterpartei Koreas
und die Armee Übernahme wie sein Vater
vereinte auch Kim Jong und absolute
Macht in seinen Händen
seitdem ist mehr als ein Jahrzehnt
vergangen ein Jahrzehnt in dem das
Einsiedler Königreich der DJ Ideologie
unter der totalen Kontrolle von Kim Jong
unstand und regelmäßig verschlagzeilen
in den internationalen Mainstream-Medien
sorgte ich bin mir sicher dass die
meisten von euch bereits mit den
wichtigsten Ereignissen genau vertraut
sind die in den letzten zehn Jahren in
diesen isolierten Land stattgefunden
haben vor allem mit seinem Aufstieg zur
Atommacht aber wie hat sich Nordkorea in
dieser Zeit wirklich verändert wie hat
das der Junge Kim geschafft seine
Führungsrolle in einem Regime zu
festigen das von Verstorbenen
halsfiguren beherrscht wird was steckt
eigentlich hinter den wichtigsten
Entscheidungen des großen Führers und
vielleicht die wichtigste Frage von
allen wohin steuert Nordkorea all das
und noch viel mehr verraten wir euch in
diesem Video also lasst uns loslegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer wie alle
können das Jahrzehnt das Kind schon und
nun an der Spitze Nordkorea steht in
vier große phasenunterteilen die erste
zwischen 2012 und 2013 war die Phase der
Konsolidierung seiner Macht die zweite
zwischen 2013 und 17 könnte man die bion
gin-phase nennen über diese werden wir
euch später noch mehr erzählen die
dritte Phase zwischen 2018 und 19 war
die Phase der Diplomatie und die vierte
Phase von 2019 bis heute könnte man als
die kovid-phase bezeichnen die ersten
beiden dieser Phasen waren ein Schub
einer entscheidende Veränderung in der
nordkoreanischen Politik die Aufweichung
der sogenannten Sohn gundoktrin
schon gut war die nordkoreanische
Doktrin welche die gesamte Politik des
vorherigen Diktators Kingdom ill
beherrscht hatte diese Doktrinen
basierte auf der Idee Army first Armee
zuerst nach der die nordkoreanischen
Streitkräfte stets Priorität vor allem
anderen besaßen mit anderen Worten der
Einsatz von verfügbaren Ressourcen
sollte stets in erster Linie auf die
Entwicklung der militärischen
Fähigkeiten des Landes gerichtet sein
das Ergebnis war der entscheidende Schub
für das nuklear und Raketenprogramm noch
Koreas im Jahr 2013 entschied kim Jong
und jedoch dass dieser Kurs
zurückgefahren werden müsse und dass die
zivile Entwicklung von nun an mit der
militärischen Entwicklung Schritt halten
sollen dazu verkündete er die
bionjin-doktrine welche sich wirklich
als Doktrin der parallelen Entwicklung
übersetzen lässt beyoncin war
ursprünglich von Kim Jong und Großvater
tim ist so in den frühen 1960er Jahren
propagiert worden und diente diesen doch
als militärischer Slogan um der eigenen
Bevölkerung die großen rüstungsanstren
verkaufen zu einer Zeit in der sich das
Land noch wieder Aufbau nach dem
Koreakrieg befand doch nach fast zwei
Jahrzehnten unter King Jong-il in denen
das Militär praktisch alleinige
Priorität in der hatte war ging schon
uns Wiederbelebung der parallelen
Entwicklungspolitik fast schon als
Kehrtwende zu sehen im Rahmen dieser
neuen Interpretation von jungen Jens
sollten die Ressourcen des Landes nicht
mehr allein für die Streitkräfte
verwendet werden sondern auch zu
Verbesserung der Lebensbedingungen der
Nordkoreaner beitragen zumindest für
diejenigen die sich den Regime gegenüber
loyal zeigen
[Musik]
aber warum eigentlich hat sich Kingdom
und nur ein Jahr nach seiner Macht
Ergreifung sondern so dramatischen
Veränderung entschlossen nur im Grunde
tat er es weil die Wirtschaft nach
Kingdom ins Regentschaft am Boden lag
nach der schrecklichen Hungersnot den
Anstrengungen zur Entwicklung von
Atomwaffen und den Niedergang der alten
und ineffizienten Industrien bei dem
Land einfach die Puste ausgegangen der
neue Regierungschef setzt also auf
diesen Politikwechsel weil er dachte
dass die Verbesserung der allgemeinen
Lebensbedingungen helfen würde seine
Macht zu festigen die Frage lautet also
hat das ganze funktioniert nun
gewissermaßen schon allerdings nicht
allzu lange schaut euch an
[Musik]
die glücklichen Jahre des neuen game
als Kingdom und Andy Macht kam
befürchtet er aufgrund seiner Jugend und
mangeln Erfahrung in den etablierten
Zirkeln der machtnordkoreas einen
internen Putsch gegen sich um in die
Macht zu entreißen und dies war durchaus
eine Möglichkeit von vielen Analysten
ernst genommen wurde schließlich war Kim
kein gewöhnlicher Nordkoreaner sondern
ein Typ der in der Schweiz studiert
hatte und ein NBA Fan war das Risiko war
also vorhanden eine solcher
hypothetische Pochette von zwei
Fraktionen kommen können von Seiten der
Armee angeführt von einigen der
traditionistischsten alten Militärführer
des Regimes oder von Seiten der Partei
unter Leitung einer
Führungspersönlichkeit die das System
reformieren wollte wie es in gewisser
Weise mit dangering in China geschehen
war und lasst mich euch eine Frage
stellen was tun Diktatoren normalerweise
wenn Sie die Möglichkeit eines
Staatsstreichs zu ihrer Entmachtung sehr
ernst nehmen na 3 2 1 ganz genau sie
errichten ein Terror-Regime handeln
schnell und führen so schnell wie
möglich eine Reihe von Säuberungen durch
die Interessen des Tyrannen gehen
schließlich vor nun das gedacht genau
das hat der nordkoreanische Führer auch
getan der Junge Diktator wollte beweisen
dass er bloß aufgrund seiner Jugend
nicht schwach ist und wenn etwas im
Laufe der Jahre klar geworden ist dann
dass dieser Mann die notwendigen Nerven
dazu hat ihr erinnert euch sicher an die
Ermordung von Kim Jong uns Bruder kim
Jong num nehmen sich im Februar 2017 auf
dem Flughafen von Kuala Lumpur zwei
Frauen von hinten näherten um ihn zu
vergiften
[Musik]
bereits 2013 hatte kim Jong und eine
viel wichtiger Hinrichtung aus
politischen Gründen angeordnet die nicht
die seines Onkels jung-song take
selbiger war ein hochrangiger
funktionierendes Regimes der nach
Vorwürfen der fraktionsbildung
Korruption Drogenkonsum Glücksspiel
erschossen wurde es handelt es sich um
eine der bedeutendsten und drastischsten
Säuberungen seit den 1950er Jahren und
die Frage ist warum hat er töten lassen
und es wird vermutet dass dieser
hochrangige Beamte sich gegen die von
Kim Jong ungeplanten neue Politik
gestellt hatte
[Musik]
in diesem Fall sollte der Junge Diktator
außerdem dafür dass das ganze Land und
die ganze Welt von diesem gamechanger
erfuhr es war so etwas wie eine Warnung
schwach wer sagt dass ich schwach bin
stellt mich nicht auf die Probe sonst
bist du der nächste und tatsache ist
dass diese Art von Säuberungen ihre
Wirkung zeigt
Nordkoreas ging schon und lässt seinen
Onkel auf spektakuläre Weise öffentlich
hinrichten seitdem ist kimsführung nicht
mehr in Frage gestellt worden zumindest
soweit wir wissen und aufgrund dessen
konnte er die neue Politik umsetzen die
der neue Führer zu seinem wichtigsten
Standard machen wollte seine Jungen Gin
Doktrin
im Rahmen dieser neuen Politik der
parallelen Entwicklung versprach Kim
seinem Volk das ist nie wieder den
Gürtel enger schnallen müsse nach dem
Jungen gin-modell wollte Kim eine
Wirtschaftsreform nach chinesischen
Vorbild durchsetzen also ohne eine
politische Öffnung so wurden zum
Beispiel private Märkte anerkannt und
ein Gesetz erlassen das staatlichen
Unternehmen mehr Autonomie einräumte die
Idee war auch ohne Privatbesitz ein
gewisses Maß an Unternehmertum
produktiver Effizienz und Wettbewerb zu
fördern und das war noch nicht alles es
wurden auch rund 20
Sonderwirtschaftszonen und ein Gesetz
über John Ventures geschaffen um
ausländisches insbesondere chinesisches
Kapital anzuziehen
natürlich reden wir über ein Land in dem
die staatliche Planung praktisch
allgegenwärtig ist deshalb wurden diese
Sonderwirtschaftszonen unter anderem in
landwirtschaftsindustrie und
tourismuszonen unterteilt die Frage die
uns nun stellen können lautet haben all
diese Reformen dazu beigetragen die
wirtschaftliche Situation des Landes zu
verbessern
[Musik]
nur die Wahrheit ist dass sie ist
anscheinend getan haben es wird
geschätzt dass die nordkoreanische
Wirtschaft 2016 ihr bestes Jahr seit
1989 hatte kurz vor dem Zusammenbruch
des Sowjetunion nicht das 1989 ein Jahr
gewesen wäre für das man eine Parabel
hätte veranstalten können nach
Berechnungen des südkoreanischen
Zentralbank sprechen wir von einem
geschätzten Wirtschaftswachstum von etwa
3,9%. diese Hochrechnungen basieren
unter anderem auf geheimdienstberichten
satellitenanalysen und der Entwicklung
der Exporte und Import aber wie dem auch
sei fakt ist das mehr Autos auf den
straßenspuren der Konsum in den
Großstädten etwas Anstieg und das Land
einen gewissen Boom im Bausektor erlebte
hier auf visualpolitik haben wir sogar
ein ganzes Video das den großen oder
eher größten wahnsinnigen Projekten
Nordkoreas gewidmet ist den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung gut
es war nicht so dass das Land auf
Hochtouren lief weit davon entfernt aber
für nordkoreanische Verhältnisse
begannen sich die Dinge zu verbessern
und diese Veränderungen mein Leben
visualpolitik Zuschauer beschränken sich
nicht auf wirtschaftlichen Bereich auch
in der Politik gab es neue Entwicklungen
[Musik]
der Junge Kim reformierte die
Machtstruktur innerhalb des Staates so
dass er schien das nicht länger die
Armee die mächtigste Instruktion im Land
war sondern die Partei das heißt unter
King Jong uns Befehl gewannen viele
zivile posten die Oberhand über
militärische
und der zumindest wurde versucht diesen
Eindruck zu schaffen in der Praxis haben
viele Militärs einfach nur ihre Uniform
ausgezogen und gegen einen Anzug
getauscht so dass von einer Entmachtung
der militärfunktionäre keine Rede sein
kann wir sprechen hier schließlich über
Nordkorea eines der am stärksten
militarisierten Länder der Welt denn der
ju-cheführer nutzte die relative
wirtschaftliche Blütezeit auch dazu um
die Entwicklung des Atom- und
Raketenprogramms erfolgreich
abzuschließen tatsächlich würde
Nordkorea 2016 und 17 zwei Atomtest
durch darunter angeblich auch eine
Wasserstoffbombe außerdem wurden
zahlreiche Tests von ballistischen
Interkontinentalraketen durchgeführt von
denen einige sogar über Japan flogen
August 2017
raketenüberflug Japan war mit einer
ominösen Warnung von nordkoreanischem
Raketenstart auf sie reden holten Züge
hielten an und Anwohner gingen in
Deckung als eine von Nordkorea
abgefeuerte Rakete 2 Minuten lang über
japanisches Gebiet flog das liebe
Freunde war natürlich eine große Sache
nordkoreanische Raketen fliegen über
Japan und lösen einer der wichtigsten
Verbündeten des Westens
raketenabwehralarm aus es war klar dass
eine Reaktion nicht lange auf sich
warten lassen würde
[Musik]
und die heiße waren diese Tests sowohl
die nuklearen als auch die ballistischen
die das hochbild von Fortschritt und
Offenheit das King schon unsere Formen
in Gang gesetzt zu haben schienen
unmissverständlich zu nicht gemacht
September 2017 Sicherheitsrat fängt
neues Sanktionen gegen die Demokratische
Volksrepublik Korea einschließlich
Verbot von erdgasverkäufen und
Arbeitsgenehmigung für ihre
Staatsangehörigen damals verhängte die
internationale Gemeinschaft die bislang
härtesten Sanktionen gegen das Land
darunter ein Verbot des verkaufs- und
Gas und strenge Beschränkungen des
Verkaufs von Öl außerdem wurde die
Abteilung von Arbeitsgenehmigungen an
Nordkoreaner verboten so dass viele der
staatlichen Unternehmen die im Ausland
tätig waren um Devisen zu verdienen ihre
Aktivitäten einstellen mussten dies
trocknet eine der wichtigsten
Finanzierungsquellen des Regimes aus
[Musik]
und wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt haben
diese Maßnahmen alles verändert die gute
Zeit ging zu Ende und die
nordkoreanische Wirtschaft viel zurück
in eine schwere Rezession in nur zwei
Jahren ging der internationale Handeln
Nordkoreas und schätzungsweise 150% von
rund sechseinhalb Milliarden auf rund
2,8 Milliarden US-Dollar zurück und auf
diese Weise wanderte Kims großer Plan
direkt in den Orkus ja die
vorherrschende Doktrin hatte sich
geändert aber was ich nicht geändert
hatte waren die Prioritäten das
Überleben des Regimes stand über allem
anderen und damit natürlich auch über
der Hoffnung der nordkoreanischen
Bevölkerung auf einen besseren
Lebensstandard die Frage ist nun was hat
Kim nach diesem Fehlschlag unternommen
was hat sich dieses heruntergekommene
Regime einfallen lassen um aus dem Loch
zu kommen passt gut auf denn ich bin mir
sicher dass viele von euch im Folgenden
ein viel klares Bild davon bekommen
werden was in Nordkorea eigentlich vor
sich geht
[Applaus]
Fake Diplomatie
[Musik]
im Jahr 2017 standen die Sterne gut für
Kim Jong-un auf der einen Seite war da
Donald Trump als Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten ein eher
ungewöhnliches Staatsoberhaupt in einem
starken populistischen Charakter dass
ich gerne damit rühmte mit jedem
Tyrannen kollektives für die USA
aushandeln zu können sogar mit dem
Herrscher der schlimmsten Diktatur der
Welt zum anderen war ein Südkorea gerade
der mittlerweile ehemalige Präsidenten
mundsche in an die Macht gekommen dieser
war ein Anhänger der sogenannten
sonnenscheinpolitik eine Politik der
Offenheit gegenüber Nordkorea die sich
Südkorea schon mal in den späten 1990er
Jahren verfolgt hatte und gibt es eine
bessere Gelegenheit für Kinder und als
ein solches Szenario auszunutzen und
sich als verhandlungsfreudiger und
kompromissbereiter Mann zu präsentieren
selbst wenn dies die den nuklearisierung
dort Koreas bedeuten würde das ist
übrigens ein alter nordkoreanischer
Taschenspieler Trick die Idee dahinter
welcher demokratischen Staatschef wird
es eine Wählerschaft nicht gerne einen
so großen politischen Erfolg wie einen
endgültigen Friedensvertrag für den
Koreakrieg verkaufen oder den Home für
sich in Anspruch Unternehmen die
Denuklearisierung der koreanischen
Halbinsel erreicht zu haben die Idee war
also für alle Beteiligten zu verlockend
[Musik]
das nordkoreanische Regime hatte erkannt
dass die UN-Sanktionen mehr Schaden
anrichteten als sie erwartet hatten
deshalb musste die Lockerung der
Sanktion erreicht werden koste es was es
wolle zumindest das nordkoreanische Volk
und der einzigen Weg dies zu erreichen
war die Verbesserung der Beziehungen zu
Washington das bedeutet alle Tests und
die ständigen militärischen
Provokationen erstmal einzustellen es
war die Zeit der Diplomatie eine
scheindiplomatie
diese Art der Diplomatie bestand darin
etwas anzubieten von dem sie genau
wussten dass sie es letztendlich nicht
liefern würden nachdem sie das erreicht
hatten was das Regime brauchte der
Verzicht auf Atomwaffen war die perfekte
Karotte um sie den Eseln Trump und Mohn
schön vor ihrer Nase baumeln zu lassen
bis sie kindskarren aus dem Dreck
gezogen hätten wisst ihr noch was Kinder
darüber gesagt hat ist dass die
Nordkoreaner den Gürtel nicht mehr enger
stellen müssten nun genau darum ging es
und so wurden wir zwischen 2018 und 19
Zeuge von zwei historischen Bildern zum
einen kehrte ein südkoreanische
Präsident nach elf Jahren wieder in
pyöngjang ein und zum anderen traf sich
ein nordkoreanischen Diktator zweimal
mit dem Präsidenten der US Open und
schüttelte in die Hand was zuvor noch
nie geschehen war es handelt es sich um
wahrlich seltsame Bilder Gespräche die
natürlich nicht lange brauchten um
spektakulär zu scheitern
die letzte Ernährung zwischen Nordkorea
den Vereinigten Staaten Südkorea fand
2019 in der vietnamesischen Stadthalle
Neustadt dieser Gipfel war ein echtes
fiasco nach fast zwei Jahren Heuchelei
hatte Kim sein eigentliches Ziel immer
noch nicht erreicht die Aufhebung des
Sanktionen gegen Nordkorea und natürlich
zog sich die ergebnislose Scharade schon
so lange hin dass sie begann Kims Image
zu beschädigen denn der nordkoreanische
Big Boss zeigte einfach schon zu lange
ein ungewohntes Bild der Schwäche
gegenüber seinem eigenen Regime sagen
wir mal er hatte seinem Erzfeind die
Hand geschüttelt und dafür absolut
nichts erreicht
infolgedessen wurde der Gipfel in Hanoi
vorzeitig beendet was nach Aussage der
Vereinigten Staaten die folgenden Gründe
hat es ging nur um die Sanktionen im
Grunde wollten sie dass die Sanktionen
in ihrer Gesamtheit aufgehoben werden
und das konnten wir nicht tun Präsident
Donald Trump
das die lebane die wir konfrontiert
waren besteht darin dass die
Nordkoreaner derzeit nicht bereits in
ihre massenvernichtungswaffenprogramme
vollständig einzufrieren eine Lockerung
der Sanktionen in Höhe von vielen vielen
Milliarden Dollar würde uns also in die
Position bringen dass wir die laufende
Entwicklung von Massenvernichtungswaffen
in Nordkorea subventionieren hohe
Beamter des US-Außenministeriums sie
haben deinen Plan durchschaut die
Schlange bis sich also selbst in den
Schwanz Nordkorea verlangte ein Ende der
Sanktionen bevor es aber zu
irgendwelchen eigenen Zugeständnissen
bereit war und die USA verlangten das
Nordkorea sein Atom und Raketenprogramm
abbaut bevor sie irgendetwas aufheben es
war klar dass eine Einigung ohne möglich
war und so viel alles auseinander und
Nordkoreas Wirtschaftskrise ging weiter
wir sind nun also im Jahr 2019
angekommen und jetzt haltet euch fest
was als nächstes passiert ist
der letzte Nagel im sackartigsten Land
der Welt
das Jahr 2019 war ein schlechtes Jahr
für das Regime von Kim Jong-un zum einen
waren die Sanktionen noch in Kraft und
es war klar dass sie nicht so bald
verschwinden würden der nordkoreanische
Staatschef hatte also keinen Anreiz mehr
weiterhin ein freundliches Gesicht zu
zeigen wozu denn auch und könnt ihr euch
denken was er dann tat nun erklärte zu
der Politik zurück die Streitkräfte um
jeden Preis zu verstärken vor allem im
Bereich der strategischen Abschreckung
vielleicht hat er das um sich vor der
Führungsspitze des eigenen Regimes
einmal mehr als harter und starker
Führer zu präsentieren vielleicht um
sein politisches Versagen mitzumachen
oder vielleicht um die Welt daran zu
erinnern dass Kim Jong ohne nun mal ein
Bad Boy ist wie dem auch sei dies
markierte das Ende seiner beyond Doktrin
und eine Rückkehr zur vorherigen Politik
auf diese Weise stellte Kim das übliche
Wirtschaftssystem weitgehend wieder her
und kehrte in seinen Reden zu Betonung
der Selbstversorgung zurück was im
Grunde eine Rückkehr zu erhalten und
strengen hautarachi bedeutet die für
Nordkorea immer charakteristisch war in
der Außenpolitik vor King Jong ohne nach
und nach alle Dialoge ein die in der
vorherigen Phase eröffnet worden waren
der dramatischste Ausdruck dafür war die
Sprengung des innerkoreanischen
Verbindungsbüros in juni 2020
natürlich dürft ihr nicht vergessen das
Ende 2019 Anfang 2020 die
coronavirus-pandemie in Gang gesetzt
wurde eine Pandemie die wir alle wisst
ihren Ursprung in China hatte und die
dazu führte dass das Regime das Land
praktisch wieder komplett dicht machte
und nicht einmal den Handel mit China zu
liest außer für lebenswichtige Güter die
nordkoreanische Wirtschaft viel also
wieder in die Rezession zurück und
angesichts der Umstände in diesem Land
wird einmal verlorenes nicht wieder
geworden mit kovid 19 ist Nordkorea zu
einem Zustand fast völliger Isolation
zurückgekehrt einen Zustand absoluter
Autarkie und extremer not etwas das sehr
ähnlich oder sogar noch schlimmer ist
als das was Kingdom und vorfand als er
2011 den Thron bestieg
und das ist noch nicht alles erschwerend
kommt hinzu dass die fehlende
Wasserinfrastruktur und die starken
Regenfälle zu manchen Zeiten des Jahres
unkontrollierte Überschwemmungen
ausgelöst und zu anderen Zeiten extreme
dürren nach sich gezogen haben dies hat
eine Nahrungsmittelkrise verursacht
deren tatsächliches Ausmaß uns noch
nicht bekannt ist
juli 2022 nordkoreanische Städte entlang
der Grenze zu China wurden diese Woche
nach heftigen Regenfällen überflutet was
die ohnehin schon kritische ernährungs-
und Wirtschaftslage im Land weiter zu
verschärfen droht
juli 2022 Nordkoreas
Nahrungsmittelknappheit könnte sich
weiter verschärfen da der Griff
überschreitende Handel aufgrund von
kovid 19 immer noch stark eingeschränkt
ist wird die Hilfe aus dem Ausland
begrenzt sein können wir angesichts all
dessen also von einem verlorenen
Jahrzehnt in Nordkorea sprechen nun nein
eigentlich ist das nicht der Fall zum
einen hat Kim Jong und sein Ziel
erreicht seine Macht zu festigen und der
Kim dynastik Kontinuität zu verleihen
was übrigens keine leichte Aufgabe zu
sein schienen zum anderen haben die
Jahre relativen wirtschaftlichen
Wohlstands zu bedeutenden städtischen
Entwicklungen in Pjöngjang sanjion und
one San geführt die unter anderem
tausenden von Nordkoreanern neue
Wohnungen sowie Hotels Krankenhäuser
unverbesserungen an mehreren Flughäfen
gebracht haben aber die Situation die
sich in den letzten zwei Jahren
entwickelt hat könnte sogar King Jong
uns Führung gefährden denn jedenfalls
scheint klar zu sein dass Nordkorea in
nahe Zukunft keinen Wohlstand
irgendeiner Art sehen wird
und konnte dies dem totalitären Regime
in der Vergangenheit eher Schluppe sein
steht es heute vor einem so großen
Problem wie noch nie die Bevölkerung
scheint ihre Not nicht mehr so einfach
ohne aufmucken wegzustecken wie früher
worauf vor allem eine erstaunliche
Tatsache hinweist während das
nordkoreanische Regime vor der Welt
nämlich mit seinen jüngsten Raketentest
herum prahlt gibt es sich vor dem
heimischen Publikum eher bescheiden im
Gegensatz zur bisherigen Praxis
berichten die nordkoreanischen
Staatsmedien nur wenig über die
Raketenstarts sondern kon sehen sich
eher auf landwirtschaftliche Themen der
nach seiner Diät im vergangenen Jahr
wieder sichtlich wohlgenährte Diktator
selbst posierte neulich lieber bei der
Gemüseernte auf einem Bauernhof aber
nicht irgendeinem Bauernhof denn dieser
war die Art richtig auf dem Gelände
eines ehemaligen Militärflugplatzes
errichtet worden der auch als
raketentestgelände gedient hatte
plakativer kann man schwer dazu
Pflugscharen nicht mehr darstellen
entgegen jahrzehntelang Geflogenheiten
feierte pseudokomonistische Tyrann den
Jahrestag der Partei Gründung nicht
einmal mit einer klassischen
Militärparade Kim weiß also genau das
seine untertane nicht ständig von teuren
Raketenstarts hören wollen wenn Sie
selbst mit realen und schier
unüberwindbaren Problemen wie Hunger zu
kämpfen haben und von der
Nahrungsmittelknappheit scheinen
mittlerweile 70% der Bevölkerung
betroffen zu sein andererseits hat Kim
dieses Jahr auch viel aus dem russischen
Krieg in der Ukraine gelernt er sieht
klar den Nutzen und die Bedeutung von
Atom die der russischen
Terroristenführer Wladimir Putin gezielt
als Abschreckung gegen einen
NATO-Intervention einsetzt die den Krieg
schnell beenden könnte er weiß die
Atombombe macht ihn von außen und an
kostbar Kind hat ein langes Jahr 2023
Zeit haben um sich zu entscheiden
welchen Kurs er für Nordkorea in der
postkowith Ära einschlagen will eine
Rückkehr zur Politik der parallelen
Entwicklung oder eine Fortsetzung der
radikalen militaristischen Autarkie und
von gundo drinnen wie zu erwarten werden
wir Office wahlpolitik alle Ereignisse
im abgeschotteten Königreich der
tyrannischen Kims genau im Auge behalten
aber jetzt seid ihr erstmal eine Reihe
glaubt ihr das klingt schon uns Führung
bis zu seinem eigenen Ableben gesichert
ist welchen Weg Web Nordkorea eurer
Meinung nach in der Zeit nachkubit
einschlagen glaubt ihr dass es aufgrund
der Krise zu einer internen Rebellion
gegen Kim kommen könnte entweder von
Seiten der Eliten des Regimes oder der
Bevölkerung wie immer sind wir auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch was dabei gelernt hat was zumindest
mit einem like das mit euren Freunden
und vergesst nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen
um keines unserer Videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
der uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den PayPal Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung oder den
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]